el resultado final es muy agridulce como
suelen ser con todas las copas después
de 25 si podríamos decir que se continúa
destinando lo que es urgente y es
estamos dilatando algo que es urgente
dada la multiplicidad de intereses en
juego
siguen se ha progresado no es suficiente
y lamentablemente estos foros suelen
estar controlados por los países que
tienen un mayor influencia y en esta
medida el resultado no es satisfactorio
a lo que demandan las circunstancias
recordemos que el ipcc
ya está cansado de insistir la gravedad
de la situación y pues por supuesto no
es suficiente lo que se logra se
necesita más amor
y pues la verdad y arte en los países
más vulnerables porque la urgencia del
cambio climático requiere mucha más
voluntad política que lo que nos deja
esta copa precisamente bueno hablando de
esa voluntad política a la que usted
hace referencia el presidente de la cob
26 a loc salma concluyó las
negociaciones diciendo ahora es momento
de tomar decisiones que usted que la
salida a la crisis es política
creo que la salida de la crisis debe ser
colectiva y amplia
entonces es mucho más que política es
multidimensional
yo invito a que todas las personas
independientemente de sus roles se
comprometan con la causa porque podemos
ver que se agota el alcance que puede
tener la cob si es importante seguir
haciendo presión y esperando que el
próximo año se insista yo leía un poco
un comentario de qué es
la acción climática
excede la cob y se digamos que se
robustece en la medida que durante el
año previo se trabaja más duro en
materia climática
tiene un poco ya adelantarte tu postura
respecto de lo que te voy a preguntar
pero bueno ya finalizó el tiempo de la
retórica será momento ahora de pasar a
los hechos los optimistas al respecto un
poco manifestante que no verdad
yo creo que no hay que perder el
optimismo digamos hay un tema muy
delicado al ser tan crítico y severo y
es que se pierde la voluntad entonces yo
trato de movilizar lo que llaman este
optimismo cauteloso muy característico
de un investigador sobre el tema y es
que debemos hacer veeduría crítica de
estos espacios y a su vez
como ciudadanos
seguirá actuando y multiplicando la
acción climática más allá de estas
esferas y estos círculos de poder porque
pues en el alcance de estos espacios es
limitado dada la magnitud y la urgencia
y todo lo que implica el cambio
climático para para un futuro que parece
un pasado muy difícil